his birth was announced with a royal gun
salute unto us a child is born and no
ordinary child a prince he was easily
the most famous baby in the world at the
age of three when his mother became
Queen Charles became the heir to the
British throne
and that was his job for the next seven
decades he was always just a little bit
of an outsider to start with stonebra
says the prince was far from popular
during his school days nobody wanted to
be his friend because if you were his
friend you were then teased brutally for
being his friend in fact stonebra says
Charles was lonely shy and badly bullied
we were playing rugby football and a
couple of the boys decided that they
were going to quite do the prince which
means beat him up you know pull his ears
punch him and he never complained he
never said a word